so Alex Jones is defaulted again it's  like Groundhog Day over here this time  in Connecticut where he faces additional  defamation suits that like the court  case in Texas he has defaulted on  because of all the shenanigans in  Discovery this time it's over some  Google analytics basically the judge  kept telling Alex Jones and his  companies to turn over data related to  Google analytics and they refuse to do  so and that data definitely existed  which the plaintiffs found out about and  brought it to the judge this stunningly  Cavalier attitude with respect to  their Discovery obligations is what led  to the default in the first place and as  a sanctioned Jones cannot argue that he  did not make a profit from the Sandy  Hook coverage Court hereby sanctions the  defendants by precluding them from  presenting evidence or argument that  they did not profit from the Sandy Hook  coverage so basically the Connecticut  cases are going just as poorly for Jones  as the Texas case did